rent how are you today I am five dad how
you doing lad I'm doing great I'm doing
great so long the new gig with the
Raiders how did this come up I was at a
hockey game one night and mr. Davis Mark
Davis and I were chatting and then he
said say would you like to do some some
broadcasting with us and you know with
the evening and had a cold one and I
said what you know sure we'll talk about
it and I thought maybe there that they
wanted me to to do some of the
pre-season television work on the not
the regular season games but before the
season started I didn't think much about
it and then mr patanè called mark
betaine he was the president of the team
and it suddenly dawned on me they were
talking about the full radio gig of
doing every game and so just it started
I wasn't you know I wasn't thinking
about going back into the booth but the
more I thought about it especially with
Jon Gruden going back to the sideline
you know Dick Vermeil worked with me for
years before he went back and and I
stayed close with dick through the years
and it's always a great story and I'm
always amused when people say uh the
game the game has passed him by I don't
think so so anyway that's how I was
that's how that's how I became about
what are your expectations for the
Raiders like in the short term long term
with Gruden well short term they've got
their hands full okay they're gonna have
about on the 53-man roster I was working
on it last night and I see 25 it could
be even up to 30 new faces from a year
ago well and I went back and I looked at
some games I was
I was kind of curious as to how they had
played so I went back and I looked at
some games from a year ago
and to tell you the truth the the office
was kind of a hit and miss you know I
I'm not sure whoever was running whoever
was running the offense for Jack Del Rio
it didn't strike me as someone who
really knew how to operate an office and
when when Gruden was first with the
Raiders the one thing they could do is
move the football John knows how to do
that
and Carr was up and down last year when
the team played well it was because he
was really at the top of his game and
when they played poorly to tell you the
truth
alright that's when he threw most of his
interceptions and turned it over but a
lot of that is on the guys who were
designing the plays Amari Cooper was
very hard to shake the double team
coverage of safeties were always coming
up over the top on him so I I think it's
gonna be a completely different team but
short term short term I would say the
Raider nation should probably have some
patience with what's going on the the
defensive secondary was dreadful last
year they had only five interceptions
and that's just horrible you know in the
NFL you've got a defense incident or
intercept 21 24 passes in the course of
a season to stay relevant
long term long term I would think
they're gonna do very very well and the
one thing the one thing that gluten did
that Vermeil didn't do if gluten came in
and tore that roster up right away
dick dick was a different kind of a
coach and then when he lost Trent green
of course it looked like it was going to
be dreadful for him with the Rams and
Along Came somebody by the name of Kurt
Warner who had been discovered by
Charlie Army when he was throwing the
ball around the European Football League
so I I would say those are gluten gluten
Zac he's a very good coach there is in
fact Vermeil called me this is kind of a
cute story
the writers wanted to talk to dick about
the hiring of Gruden and one of the
writers said can you believe can you
believe that they're paying him ten
million dollars a year and Vermeil fires
back it's about time House house
coverage been with legalized gambling
has it affected Vegas at all not really
you know Danner's there's conventions
and California doesn't have it so you
know those people are still coming in I
suppose you'd have to wait until Super
Sunday to see if the handle is off in
Nevada how many people who might have
come from the East Coast and wind up in
Atlantic City
but so far you know they're very
negligible there was your World Cup was
probably not as appealing to the Vegas
betters as it was to the New York New
Jersey crowd simply because of time of
day but now now we haven't noticed it
how's Vegas treating you you know Dan
it's damn hot down there who saw that
coming Brent yeah you know told me I
know how to get to the desert but no one
but I like it and I Drive by I can't
believe the number of cranes from where
I stay actually I can with a set of
binoculars I can see the construction on
the on the new stadium and they got a
workforce down there about five hundred
and they say they're on schedule the one
the one thing about getting that stadium
finished is that you can work you know
you can work through the winter you're
not up against real bad weather and the
crews are going around the clock and
later the lead so did you know Vegas is
great it's always it has always
interested me and the shows and good
food and things of that nature and it's
so much larger than when I first lived
there to tell you the truth it's
it's a metropolitan area now and the
success of the Golden Knights was was
really a story to be around the city
rallied around them dad there's a lot of
fun yeah what advice would you give the
new gamblers those are going to be
different their toe in this you know
with legalized gambling be careful okay
I will tell you right now that now not
many people can beat those numbers over
a daily weekly however you want to do it
if you've never if you've never been
around it never experienced it you know
listen listen to what people tell you
how to approach it but don't think that
you're gonna walk in and say this is my
life this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
make a good living at this I can beat
these numbers I'm here to tell you you
can't there are a few listen let's be
honest there's a few guys who in a few
syndicates that have been pretty
successful at it over the years but
there's a reason why those casinos get
bigger and bigger and my my warning
would be you know just kind of tiptoe in
stay in the shallow end and and
everybody should know that there's
trouble gamblers out there if you've got
a problem seek some help you know I
approach it from a recreation standpoint
and everybody knows that I'm in leagues
contest competitions I have fun with it
but it's nothing more for me than the
recreation it's something to be
interested in I would never ever as much
as I'd been around it I would never ever
say I have a professional example I'm
gonna make a living at doing this
because it is flat hard okay and there's
a lure there's an appeal I got it but I
would say just just approach it
carefully because it'll bite you and
that's that that's how you do it towards
for recreation there's not guys who pet
horses but $2.00 a race well but
about $10 a game if you want to do it on
a on a weekend and and have some fun
with it but don't the very few very very
few do really really well with it
Brent good to talk to you Congrats on
the Raider gig and we'll catch up with
you during the regular season thanks dad
all right Brent Musburger joining us
from Montana as he realized he gets
really hot in Las Vegas in July for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]